oui il n'ya pas que l'accès à
l'avortement qui soulève des inquiétudes
dans le projet de loi 20 les changements
proposés au programme de procréation
assistée attire également son lot de
critiques mais julie vous avez appris
que le ministre barrette est ouvert à
revoir la limite d'âge
oui parce que vous savez ces lignes dans
sa mouture actuelle le projet de loi 20
limite carrément ou en fait interdit
carrément l'accès à la fécondation in
vitro aux femmes qui sont âgés de moins
de 18 ans mais surtout à celles qui sont
âgés de plus de 42 ans et cet aspect là
la question de l'âge limite a été
vertement critiqué en commission
parlementaire par plusieurs groupes
notamment le conseil du statut de la
femme et l'association des obstétriciens
et des gynécologues du québec
alors selon nos informations et à trois
scénarios qui sont à l'étude
actuellement par le bureau du ministre
barrette
alors c'est en l'occurrence de revoir la
limite d'âge de la faire passer par
exemple de 42 à 45 ou 48 ans on pense
aussi à l'essai au jugement du médecin
de déterminer si sa patiente est en
mesure de pouvoir avoir accès à une
fécondation in vitro ou non ou carrément
de dayraut patiente si vous êtes prêts à
payer et à assumer les risques vous
pourrez avoir cette décoration in vitro
alors le ministre en fin de journée n'a
pas voulu commenter ces scénarios mais
il s'est définitivement montré ouvert un
amendement le voici les commissions
parlementaires servent à justin vogel ou
en fonction des commentaires
idéalement d'experts et je pense qu'ici
et beaucoup d'expertisé qui a été
exprimée à cette commission aussi voilà
je serais très surpris si rapport
certains ajustements des deux côtés de
la loi les ajustements la la
consultation publique sur le projet de
loi 20 s est terminée ce soir est-ce
qu'on entrevoit d'autres changements
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes
beaucoup de confusion aussi et on l'a
entendu jusqu'à la toute fin céline vous
savez cet amendement l'a donc est
probablement l'un des seuls ou en tout
cas un rares amendements qu'on verra à 7
ce projet de loi là vain le ministre
demeure immuable sur la question de la
procréation assistée et de la gratuité
ou la non gratuité du service
il demeure aussi immuable sur la
question des quotas de médecins vous
l'avez entendu aujourd'hui
mais ce projet de loi là et comme le
projet de loi disent au coeur de la
grande réforme en santé du gouvernement
couillard alors si ça se passe comme on
l'a vu avec le projet de loi dit ce qui
est fait sur l'abolition des agences de
santé et qu'il y a de l'opposition
parlementaire comme on l'a vu à l'époque
eh bien on peut imaginer qu'à la fin de
la session en juin le gouvernement va
adopter à nouveau le bâillon ça se
terminerait de la même façon mais
reprend bruno vigier
merci beaucoup j'ai dit au revoir